thank you
[Music]
hey good news though uh the Bikini
Baristas of Everett Washington have won
a case against a proposed ordinance that
would make their business illegal do you
understand any of that no others there's
no way Bikini Baristas are all I heard
was girls in bikinis I I bet I could
tell the Vietnamese ones all right so
you ever seen these little uh little
coffee Huts in the middle of a parking
lot that look like one person can fit in
them okay do you remember those film
developing little Huts yeah okay it's
those they got turned into little coffee
shop things that you drive up and you
order coffee you go up to the window
you'll see a girl and she's like in
underwear or bikini inch making your
coffee yeah oh that's like Taiwan dude
yeah they have those these little glass
cases and you buy what is it the beetle
nuts
yeah and then the beetle nuts [ __ ]
gangster all over all over Taiwan
especially like uh on the outskirts of
the city they have a ton of those things
have you guys tried that bin lump thing
yeah what is it what is it like it's
like chewing tobacco It's Like Cocaine
actually really yeah when you because
there's ginseng so it's like an extract
jeans
dude it's like uh watch read that [ __ ]
it's bad for you um [ __ ] it makes
your heart palpitate like crazy dude
yeah and you just [ __ ] literally you
feel up but you feel like one of those
heavy internal ups but it's not just a
nut though I think the nut is healthy
maybe but they have like a leaf and they
literally they put
which is like I think it's crack on it
that's what I'm saying there's something
about it when you're chewing it it's
[ __ ] two episodes in a row so it's
not natural is it no not the way the
white stuff they do a paste on the leaf
but my uncle makes it
your uncle's a beetle nut yeah yeah no
they have a small shop and then yeah but
it's bad for you watching Google that
[ __ ] it's bad for you but that's why we
chewed up like half a bag before we
realized how bad it was hard it ruins
your teeth too yeah my uncle both of my
uncles don't really have teeth because
of beetle nuts but then how does it feel
don't tell me all the negatives help
with it it feels good but then caffeine
does that though no but you know it's
kind of like you know when you uh when
you drink like a cafe so that but you
have to sit here and you can't use your
energy and then out of nowhere you go
yeah it's like that yeah that's a good
joke yeah anxiety how'd you took some no
I just heard about it you're the drug
dealer all right back to the story so
you go up to these things these little
boots and then you order coffee they'll
make you a coffee you if you tip a
little they might give you a little bit
of a show
and then that was kind of like a big
thing and did you make a coffee though I
don't know we don't even have those here
they do that yeah we don't have them
here that's not a thing whichever maybe
I don't know where they are this is in
Washington oh why don't we have yeah
like I think we have some of those but
yeah so uh there was an ordinance that
was very obviously directed against them
what was the ordinance it made it so
that anyone working in fast food had to
have clothing covering the top lame
let people get their money dude well
isn't it come over
it yeah kind of I mean they're wearing
bikinis but then you know like they get
touched sometimes though because yeah
yeah you don't know people they you can
reach in and like grab and stuff oh that
sucks yeah no I mean they want oh they
want it I mean if they wanted they allow
it yeah
oh that sucks if it's consensual yeah go
for it yeah but also let people make
their money dude I don't like that shot
I don't like people so the way they were
able to overturn it is they uh they were
able to show that this ordinance
disproportionately affects women because
it's mainly women that are doing this so
because of that it's unconscious gender
bias to it yeah exactly so it's
unconstitutional if some kind of
audience is like obviously targeting one
gender yeah
do it yeah so it's not gonna pass they
threw it out yeah yeah so they can
continue on it's just so funny how like
certain markets only work for guys yeah
I mean like there could never be the
reverse version no but this ordinance
could negatively affect the pimp
that's so nice
but yeah that's we don't have something
like that here at least I don't think we
do it means coffee shops yeah but we
don't got no drive up little wow do you
think that could work out here
yeah anywhere in the world it feels so
unsafe like it's really unsafe sometimes
because in Taiwan they'll have like
these news things where they do the
gravy grabs but then they're too horny
so they like held on to the girl even
when they're in the car that's why they
need a pimp sometimes nah they need to
[ __ ] do the glass only just look only
no touchy nobody yeah oh dude you know
that way you can keep this one team
blade that drops if the hand stays in a
tube yeah they push a button yeah
cut the arm do they have a picture of
what the booth looks like yeah I'll show
you a whole video of what that looks
like yes please for you know knowledge
is it espresso or do they do pour over
you know that's one thing how's the
coffee where I feel like
it's like it's almost like you can
always have like more like food right
like like every day you need to eat yeah
every day I could look at a beautiful
woman yeah every day it doesn't get old
for me
I was like
it's like an unlimited resource that you
could continuously support yeah
and I don't know
um I'm not a big only fans dude but I
think if this was a copy kind of
situation I would get it because it's
like why would I rather go to Starbucks
like I would rather go to this
all right in the start the morning with
a with a pretty girl serving you coffee
that's way [ __ ] better I I would
imagine I don't I've never seen this but
I would imagine that it probably takes a
while for the people to get their coffee
yeah but what are you looking at while
you're waiting that's what I'm saying
like that's the game though like for
them it's in their best interest to take
as long as they can to make the coffee
so then they can might get a better or
they drop the coffee yeah like ooh the
sugar packet sorry how many sugars you
know like so people so if you're wanting
to just get coffee obviously you're not
there just to get coffee that's a true
wake me up though you got to be in a
hurry if you see a hot girl in a bikini
that's a that's that combined with
coffee that will wake me up immediately
yeah that's a perfect comment it's a
very good answer yeah
the best part of waking sorry I have to
go to porn sites to find action okay oh
really really
okay but the thing is like with the
grabby grab Booth things sometimes if I
don't ever find them like I don't like
them they don't really turn me on They
Don't Really Turn Me On like that
because every time I look at it I feel
like man but all the guys already
looking sorry that sounded like
something that sounded like some fapping
right there all right we can't show this
but like let's just just react
so here's where they all go on your side
no no I'll show it to you but here's
what it looks like when you drive up to
one of these things just so you know why
is it illegal
it's not illegal it's just uh I heard
yeah how many guys are jerking off on
sad
oh wanna play a game
it looks like this
what it's like full nude right what this
is after tipping right and they let you
record too yeah I mean if you tip enough
I mean I mean well because they're
strippers not all of them but this
particular one wow
wow that is a wake up call oh wake up
call you guys ever seen anything like
this no no not in the opening
wow
that is not sanitary this is the best
coffee I've ever seen
yeah how is her [ __ ] so wet right now
because how many times did she do this
that is still wet because she probably
got [ __ ] 200 so she's like hell yeah
this is super wet right now
it's still going on yeah see this is
taking way too long for your coffee how
much is this car by the way by the way
there's two people recording right now
because one guy's recording the other
guy recording bro yes how much is this
coffee like this is better than a lap
dance is this a 20 copy yeah bro it has
to be what's the stream even this bro I
don't know how much it is there's no way
they do twenty dollars you don't even
get that much at a strip club for 20
bucks yeah is is her friend making
coffee in the back like these guys
aren't making coffee at all after that I
don't want the coffee I don't think
they're selling coffee no but what about
if they give you the coffee and then
they give you that that is not gonna
pass the sanitation department so here's
what here's what a typical Booth would
look like so you're drinking the coffee
like this while you're looking at [ __ ]
being finger banged
all right so not not every shirt
that every place will do that what is
that [ __ ] big bear
hey we need to go to Big Ben that's
Angela's Crest bro you know what they do
they probably just do that okay they
just might have the instant coffee with
the water they Stir It Up and they're
like here you go they just microwave it
and then they start jacking themselves
off not doing any coffee
foreign so now you guys know because the
article would have never said that but
the Bikini Baristas thing that's what a
lot of them are really like I didn't
know they're doing that all that that's
why the people are having an ordinance
against it because that's what they're
thinking is really that's what they're
trying to prevent this nobody was
talking about finger banging I know
that's the thing about flicking the
people trying to prevent that that's
what I'm saying it's like an Ethics
thing with like whatever [ __ ] it's
the Peet's Coffee across the street and
the guys aren't getting their work done
because they're just watching through
the [ __ ] window not the fact that
they're losing sales is that their
employees aren't working they're like yo
yo she's doing it again she got tips she
got tips but that that already yo making
coffee with finger bang fingers that's a
sanitation violation what they need to
do is make sure that they wash their
hands and they gotta wash their hands
and then yeah
and when they use the paper towel you
gotta close does she have a ServSafe
[ __ ] certification dude she needs to
put on rubber gloves and then do that
and then at the end she needs to take
her rubber gloves off and throw it away
each time oh wow every time do you think
she could work at a doobie
yes but I have to teach her how to be
sanitary every time because Dad I'd be I
man I'd come down on her very hard you
would come out no way oh Grace as a boss
I I would I'd be like hey check this out
Vanessa
um you're doing a good job people love
your performance but you but what you
gotta do is make sure that you wash your
hands before if you're not gonna use
gloves wash your hands before and after
what if the business started going down
after she washes her hands and use
gloves would you be like ah it's okay
go back out your question go back how it
used to be yeah what if it just drops a
little bit
yeah people like the special taste I
don't know man then I'd have to change
my branding to being like customers
wrong no it's got It's I gotta change it
to ethically Source organic human sauce
June [ __ ]
[Music]